- It is no cliche that if you
work for a consulting firm
you will likely create lots of slides.
And so in the six years I worked
for the consulting firm, McKinsey,
I probably created really
thousands of PowerPoint pages.
And so today's coffee
break here on my channel,
I wanna share some additional
tips on exactly the topic
and specifically on the
thing that arguably is
both the most important
part of slide writing
but also the most challenging
in the life of anyone working
in professional services.
And this is creating charts
and diagrams that first, look professional
and then also communicate your message
in an effective and concise
and to the point way
I'm very proud that this video
is sponsored by think-cell.
Think-cell is a plugin
for PowerPoint and Excel
that is used by most of
the large consulting firms.
And I probably use it
literally every single day
but more about them in a moment.
So the plan for this
video is the following.
First, I'm going to talk
about chart formatting
so how to make sure that your charts
really look professional.
Second, I'm going to talk
about chart selection.
One of the most important
things to get right
is really to choose the right
chart type for your data.
And we're going to do this
with some little exercises.
So it's going to be very hands on.
And the last but not least,
I'm going to talk about
some typical errors
that people employ when
they work with charts
with data in creating slides.
So without further do let's get into it,
let's talk about chart formatting.
So let's look at this example of a chart.
Let's just look at the
formatting, so how this looks.
What do you think?
Is this chart looking professional?
Should you make a chart
that looks like this?
And feel free to pause maybe for a moment
and potentially think about
how you could improve this.
So take a couple of seconds if you like
and now I wanna improve this
chart together with you.
And the first thing that
likely comes to mind
is all these colors in the chart.
So should you really use
that many different colors
for all these different bars?
(indistinct) general idea is
that there's nothing wrong
with using colors in your chart.
You should just make sure
that colors have a meaning,
colors should convey a
message, then you can use them.
You shouldn't just use colors
for the sake of making
everything colorful.
And so here for this chart,
I would recommend you to
rather use toned down colors,
very basic colors because I'd
argue all these colors here
don't really help you to
bring across any message.
If at all it is this directing
from what you wanna show.
And then maybe you can set an accent,
a color accent on the latest
year to stress that this is
the newest number.
Here in the time series, the latest figure
that you maybe also wanna
focus on with your chart.
The next thing that might come to mind
is all these lines that you see here.
It just looks very crowded,
very busy, even though actually
the numbers that you're trying
to show here are quite basic
and simple.
So probably the first
thing I wanna take out,
all these connector
lines between the bars,
I'd argue they don't really add any value
at all here in this chart.
And the same thing is likely also true
for all these (indistinct)
lines, all these grid lines
in the background.
And here I'd argue what I'd take out
is also the Y axis to the side.
In this example, you
already have all the numbers
on top of the bars.
Why do you need to show
this additional axis
take it out and you will be very fine.
And now let's also look at the X axis
because it comes with
a very bold, dominant
dark black that really
dominates the picture.
So I'd say it's not really helpful
because of course you
want rather the numbers
the bars to stand out and
not this very broad X axis.
So let's lighten it up a little bit.
And now what I would encourage you to add
are rather some arrows,
different arrows, some elements
that really help you to
bring out the message
that you wanna bring out.
And of course, what exactly that is,
it will depend on indeed, the message
that you do wanna communicate
but maybe you wanna show
how the revenues increased
from 2015 to 2021.
Maybe this is what you would want to show.
And if this is indeed the case,
why don't include a difference arrow
that shows how the
revenue increased by 400%
from 2015 into 2021.
And then this will potentially be a number
that you could also cite and
refer to in the action title.
So if you don't know
what action titles are,
also a very important
part of slide writing,
I will link another video that I did
on this very topic above here.
So one key concept to have in mind here
is the idea of the data-to-ink ratio.
The idea is that this ratio
should be as high as possible.
So ideally you're able to show
as much data as possible with
as little ink as possible.
An implication of this is
that you should just take out,
delete all the additional
filler lines, (indistinct) lines
background lines, axes
and so on and so forth.
Unless of course they really
needed and really add value
to the a message that
you want to bring across.
So always think data-to-ink ratio
and this alone will already
improve your charts, I promise.
Next, let's talk about
choosing the right chart time
for the data that you want to visualize
because this idea is of more
complicated than it might look.
So let's start with this
very simple exercise here.
You see different products
and how much revenue
they contribute to the
total revenue of a company.
So the sum of them all
is a hundred percent.
So what chart type would you
choose to visualize this?
And again, feel free to
take a couple of seconds.
Maybe pause the video to
think about this indeed.
Now let's look at a couple of examples
because at least from my experience,
the chart type that people
will mention most frequently
in the situation is a pie chart.
So we should surely use a pie chart
to visualize this, right?
But here what you directly
see in this example
is that this pie chart looks
quite messy, quite overcrowded.
The basic rule of thumb
is that whenever you have
more than about five elements to show,
pie charts are quite
difficult to work with
because the elements are
just getting too small
to really display them in
a visually appealing way.
But then also at least if you
read the literature on that,
just interpreting the area of an element
does not really seem to be too
intuitive to the human mind.
So is it really that clear
to you that for instance,
product nine is twice the share,
twice the size of product 10
or product five is twice
the size of product nine.
So these relative differences in area
are not that natural to
grasp and to understand
and often about bar charts like this
as shown here on the right
might be a bit more of an intuitive way
of also really comparing even
relative numbers like this.
And the key point that I wanna make here
is that in the beginning
of visualizing data,
always make it an effort of yours.
So thinking about what
the options might be
and what really the best choice
of a chart might be for that.
And of course, some chart
types just work better
for some specific types
of data than for others.
So here, for instance,
a couple of arch types.
So component comparison.
So relative comparison, here, pie charts
or stacked column charts
might work quite well.
So for things of share of,
percentage of and so on,
if it's more about an absolute comparison,
then you maybe want to go
for the vertical bar charts
or the waterfall charts.
For time series of course line charts
or column charts might work.
So if you really wanna show
how a certain time series
develops over time, then of
course they have distributions,
correlations and so on and so forth.
I would actually
encourage you to print out
this specific slide and potentially
keep it as a cheat sheet
next to your desk.
I will offer this slide as a
PDF for you to be downloaded.
There's a link to that
in the video description
you're free to just check it out.
So now with that knowledge in mind,
let's look at another example
of a data visualization.
So this is a slightly
more complicated data set.
You'll see different numbers,
marketing spend unit price,
volume sold, for different
products that are here.
And the question is which
chart type would you choose
to communicate that the marketing spend
correlates with the unit
price, but not with the volume?
What chart type would you choose here?
And again, take a break,
pause a couple of seconds.
Think about this for yourself.
Maybe feel free to
already download the sheet
we talked about a second
ago for you to look at
and then decide which chart
type you want to pick.
And indeed there're actually several ways
of how to visualize this,
one example here would
be these bubble charts.
So let's say bubble
charts are always great
when you have three number
dimensions that you wanna have
in one chart.
So here the X axis has the marketing spend
and the Y axis, the unit price.
And I think you can very
well see the correlation.
You could now also insert a trend line
if you would want to really
make that more salient.
But then also you see in
the size of the bubbles,
that the areas of these bubbles
represent the volume sold.
And the other thing,
it's also pretty clear
there doesn't seem to
be a clear correlation
between the volume sold
and the marketing mix.
You see large bubbles, both on the left
and on the right side of the spectrum.
So now if you wonder how you
really create charts like this
because maybe you're
struggled a little bit
with the built-in PowerPoint charts,
I can very much understand you.
The built-in PowerPoint charts
are indeed often quite
a hassle to work with,
which is why a service
like think-cell exists.
So think cell is a plugin
for PowerPoint and Excel.
That really helps you to
create beautiful looking charts
and just improve your
PowerPoint workflows in General.
Think-cell is the sponsor of today's video
and all the charts you've seen so far
and you will see us in the next minutes
are created with think-cell.
Think-cell is not just any tool.
It is the (indistinct) or standard
for creating charts in PowerPoint.
Most of the large consulting firms use it.
It's also very popular in
industry and in business school.
It's a tool that I
might save literally use
almost every single day.
You just need to install think-cell
then it integrates with
PowerPoint as a plugin.
You will see a little
eye icon in the ribbon
to access all the functionality
or the formatting things that we did
at the beginning of this video.
This was all think-cell functionality.
If you create charts with think-cell
and send it to someone without think-cell,
that person can also
open it and look at it
and what's even better is that
they can also add the chart
without having think-cell installed.
So if you would like to try it out,
think-cell agreed to an exclusive offer
just for the Firm Learning community.
So if you access think-cell via the link
in the video description that
I will place there for you,
you would access to an
extended 60 day free trial.
The trial is completely
free, no hidden cost,
no auto subscription,
no credit card required.
Just the best opportunity for you to try
whether think-cell works
great for you as well
And the best thing is that I negotiated
a second goodie for you.
So if after the trial,
if you are interested
to continue using think-cell,
you will now have access
to a single license.
So in the past, you
always needed to purchase
a minimum of five licenses
to use think-cell.
For you, if you use the link
in the video description,
this is not needed anymore.
You can just purchase a single license
and trust this alone will make things
so much more affordable to you.
And also if you're interested
to join consulting in the future,
getting familiar with think-cell,
via the extended free
trial is for sure good idea
because chances are higher
than your consulting firm
will use think-cell as well.
And surely it's a great
idea to be prepared.
So with all of this in mind,
let's look at a third example
of choosing the right chart type.
So here you have the example of a P and L.
So profit and loss statement of a company,
one of the three key financial statements
the companies need to produce.
So let's imagine you
would want to visualize
this P and L in a chart, which
one would you like to choose?
And here again, pause a moment.
Think about this.
Maybe this is less trivial, less clear
because indeed one chart
type that is extensively used
in consulting that is very well suited
also to visualize things like P and Ls
are the waterfall charts.
So what we have here is
the data entry window
of think-cell, you can see that
I already copied in all the numbers.
The letter E stands for equals.
Some things (indistinct) can help you
to automatically calculate
totals and sub-totals.
So no need to do this manually anymore.
Think-cell will do the
calculations for you
and provide you with the correct results.
And also notice how you can
stack waterfall segments
just by writing the
numbers under each other
here in the column for the personnel cost.
And indeed, this is the resize,.
this is what the waterfall
chart will look like
but now you're already seeing a problem.
And this is because all
the numbers are entered
in million, right?
So the numbers are quite long.
This is surely not how you
would want them to look like.
So what do you do now?
Do you need to now go back
to the data entry mask
and change all the numbers or the Excel,
by the way, you can also
integrate things that are in Excel
to automatically update charts like this.
Well, of course not
because one of the many very handy things
and functionalities is that
just with a couple of clicks,
you can really transport
all these numbers.
And for instance, round them to millions
as I'm doing right here just
with a couple of clicks,
you have really the chart bar
exactly the way that you want it to look.
So now last but not least, let's
look at some typical errors
that people do when they create charts.
And I think one of the main problems is
if you just use the
built-in PowerPoint charts,
so not use the think-cell
charts, then often these charts
come already pre-configured
with some problem.
So all the charts you see right here
are design templates that
are suggested layouts,
suggested designs within PowerPoint.
So here you see charts
with these glossy effects,
with shadows, with 3D effects,
with these real shaded backgrounds.
So now we could look into
this in much more detail
but I hope that you agree just
at the first look and feel,
that these charts don't
really look professional.
So let's just look here at this
profitability surface chart
which again is one of the
suggested templates by PowerPoint.
how this looks, I mean
it's virtually impossible
to get really any insight,
any message out of this chart
at all, just to distill any
number out of it at all.
So you should really avoid
all layouts like this.
I think we now extensively
already talked about formatting.
I wanna leave you with
one last piece of advice
because this is something
that I often also see
done wrongly and this is in general
trying to avoid having
too many different charts,
too many different messages on one slide.
There is the basic rule of thumb
which says, one message per slide.
Really try to stick to
one search per slide.
This usually makes the whole
storytelling much easier,
helps you to create more to
the point, nicely formatted,
nicely layout pages, several
charts on one page can be okay
but only if you really
need all these charts
next to each other, to really
get the one message out
that you want to share,
otherwise rather split it up
and show them on different pages.
So now after I've shared all this advice,
of course I'd love to hear from you.
Do you have any tips and
suggestions for working with data,
working with charts and
PowerPoint that you like to share?
Please just leave a comment
in the comment section.
to us, this will be insightful
to all the other people
reading the comments this way.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe and turn
on the notification bell
to say up to date on all my content.
Also big thanks to the
members of Firm Learning
for supporting the channel
and a big shout out again
to think-cell for supporting this channel
by sponsoring this video.
If you'd like to try
out things out yourself,
you can access it via the
link in the video description,
you will get access to an
extended 60 day free trial.
And after the trial, you have
access to single licenses
which is not the standard
offering of think-cell.
So try out think-cell and see for yourself
whether it has that much of an impact
on how you create slides
as much as for sure
has for me.
Thanks to all of you.
My name is Heinrich, I
release weekly videos.
See you on Firm Learning,
looking forward to talk
to you again next week.
Until then all the best
to you and bye bye.